So the error suggests that the system or the
program, it can not find the file specified. You
know, that's really interesting because at one point we
were able to find all of the files. In fact
we printed out all of the file names. Okay,
let's continue to read the error. It says that the
error is in line 9, and it's happening around
os.rename. This makes me wonder if the program is actually
looking at the right folder when it's trying to rename the files. So going back
to our program, I know there is this function called os.getcwd.
CWD stands for Current Working Directory. Let me save that in a variable
and print it. And I will comment everything else out for the time being.
Let me Save, and Run.
It seems that the programs Current Working Directory is
this folder called OOP, which resides in the C drive.
And if I go back to my program, I know
that my files or my photos are inside this folder
called prank, which is inside OOP which resides in the
C drive. No wonder the program can't find any of
the files. It's looking inside OOP. Meanwhile, all of the
files are inside prank. To fix this, I can use
the change directory function. And with this function I can
ask the program to look at the folder where my
files actually reside, which is this folder right here. So
I'm going to copy that, and I'm going to paste it here.
And then let me uncomment some of the lines
I'd commented out before. Towards the end of the function,
I will change the path back to how I found
it. Let me Save, and Run the program one more
time. Hm, the program didn't quite throw an error
this time. But now I want to check to see if
the files have actually been renamed. So here we are
back at our folder, and you'll notice that the names
of the files don't have any numbers any more.
They've been renamed. And if I zoom out a
little bit, you'll notice that the photos will reveal
a secret message, which is that the keys are
in the closet behind the shoebox. All right, it
seemed like our program worked. Now, before we finish
this project, my final recommendation in terms of improving
it, is to add a print statement each time
we change the name of a file. So here I am printing
the old name of the file, and here is its new name.